[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich möchte dir eine kleine frage stellen
und du weißt mir immer dass es sich
nicht lohnt die antwort bei datango
wikipedia oder sonst gut zu suchen wo
der institute befinden sich die meisten
kunstwerke der welt ich bin mir sicher
dass die meisten von euch an das british
museum in london den louvre in paris
oder das moma in new york denken oder
nun tut mir leid aber das alles wäre
falsch
ok es stimmt dass all diese museen
gigantische sammlungen beherbergen und
dann müssten wir auch noch genau
definieren was wir aus kunst ansehen und
muss nicht aber freunde unabhängig von
all diesen problemen gibt es eine
gigantische fundgrube kunst andy du
wahrscheinlich noch nie gedacht hast um
unsere frage vom anfang beantworten zu
können müssen wir nämlich nach genf in
die schweiz reisen und uns dort sehr
sehr genau umsehen nur mit viel glück
werden wir einen ganz besonderen ort
finden ein ort der eine der größten
sammlungen der welt und sicherlich die
größte menge an kunst pro quadratmeter
beherbergt aber weder du noch ich werde
niemals in der lage sein diese
kunstwerke zu genießen denn ich spreche
über den freihafen von games
[Musik]
ja ich mache keine witze die rede ist
wirklich von einem hafen in genf einem
der wichtigsten freihäfen der welt sogar
und du fragst dich jetzt natürlich was
das für ein quatsch sein soll wo du
kennst weder meer noch an einem
bedeutenden fluss mit warenverkehr liegt
also für diejenigen die damit nicht
vertraut sind freihäfen sind ganz
einfach orte mit sehr laxen vorschriften
und verdammt niedrigen steuern die idee
dahinter ist den warenverkehr zu
erleichtern 1888 gegründete genfer
freihafen befindet sich neben einem
großen bahnhof mit einem trockenen hafen
verwahren und anders als man meinen
könnte ist er weder ein sperrgebiet noch
ein streng geschützter ort der von
riesigen zollen mauern und einer menge
wachpersonal umgeben wäre
die wahrheit ist dass sich die größten
kunstsammlungen der welt in ein paar
unscheinbaren gebäuden befinden die wenn
sie in deiner stadt wären sicherlich
unbemerkt bleiben würden und jetzt passt
gut auf denn diese lagerhäuser
beinhalten so viele kunstwerke dass
nicht einmal die leiter des freihafens
in der lage sind genauere zahlen darüber
zu nennen um die eine vorstellung davon
zu geben schätzt man dass hinter seinen
mauern tausende und abertausende jahr
zehntausende werke von so herausragenden
künstlern wie leonardo da vinci van gogh
renoir und el greco mit unzähligen
anderen lager es wird zum beispiel
vermutet dass hier alleine mehr als 1000
werke von picasso aufbewahrt werden
nach einer prüfung durch schweizer
beamte aus dem jahr 2012 wurde
festgestellt dass es sich um etwa eine
million 200.000 kunstwerke handeln
könnte und das ist nur eine schätzung
somit haben es mit der top 3 der
weltweiten mega sammlungen zu tun und
vergiss nicht dass wir über eine prüfung
aus dem jahr 2002 sprechen es wird
vermutet dass der aktuelle bestand
mittlerweile extrem angeschwollen sein
könnte
um dir die größenordnung zu
verdeutlichen über die wir hier sprechen
die national gallery in london verfügt
über etwa 2300 gemälde und die sammlung
des museum of modern art in new york und
fast gut 200.000 kunstwerke
verschiedener art wir sprechen also
nicht nur über das größte theater kunst
auf den ganzen planeten sondern wenn wir
auch die qualität und den wert der dort
gelagerten werte berücksichtigen dann
könnte man mit ihnen wahrscheinlich die
beeindruckendste kunstgalerie der welt
schaffen also möchtest du mehr über
diesen geheimnisvollen und
atemberaubenden ort erfahren was hältst
du davon in einem markt einzutauchen der
so geheimnisvoll ist wie kaum ein
anderer dann nichts wie los
[Musik]
der freihafen von get zufluchtsort oder
versteckt seien wir ehrlich die
tatsächlichen waren und zahlen die in
wenn es drei hafen umgeschlagen werden
sind unbekannt selbst die direktorin des
freihafens sind nicht in der lage
konkrete zahlen zu nennen
[Musik]
was wir über diesen keines vollen ort
wissen ist dass der wert der hier
gelagerten werke zwischen gemälden
skulpturen antiquitäten und kunstwerke
aller art schlicht und einfach
unbezahlbar ist wir haben es mit nichts
geringerem als dem größten kunst schafft
dieses planeten zu tun außerdem ist
dieses kunst lager zu einem guten
geschäft für den kanton genf geworden
der nicht nur fast 90 prozent der
anteile an diesen zwei jahren besitzt
sondern auch jedes jahr einnahmen von
mehr als zehn millionen dollar daraus
bezieht aber warum bewahren große
sammler und große vermögen ihre
sammlungen an diesem ort auf und nicht
an einem anderen welche vorteile bietet
er ich bin mir sicher dass viele von
euch sich genau jetzt das fragen nun
kein wunder denn der handel mit
kunstwerken ist eines der
rätselhaftesten geschäfte die es gibt
aber bevor der ford fahrer noch ein
hinweis glaube nicht dass gangster
einzige steuerfreie kunstbunker auf der
welt ist einer der bedeutendsten
befindet sich in der nähe des flughafens
von singapur und deine der jüngsten
wurde in delaware in den vereinigten
staaten eröffnet mit anderen worten
dieses konzept ist nicht einzigartig
auch wenn denn die größte einrichtung
dieser art ist
wie du gleich erfahren wird ist der
genfer freihafen auch wenn er nur einer
der zehn freihäfen und 245 freizonen ist
dies in der schweiz gibt zum großen
steuerparadies für großinvestoren in
diesen markt geworden einer der
hauptvorteile ist die möglichkeit im
freihafen selbst transaktionen zu
tätigen das heißt werke zu kaufen und zu
verkaufen ohne dafür steuern zahlen zu
müssen solange die waren den freihafen
nicht verlassen sind alle geschäfte
steuerfrei außerdem sind die lagerung an
diesem ort und die einfuhr auch
steuerfrei und das ist wichtig denn
freunde in den meisten ländern dann
zölle und steuern zwischen fünf und 15
prozent für die einfuhr und kunstwerken
fällig
[Musik]
natürlich sind die steuervorteile nicht
das einzige was die größten kunst aller
welt dazu bringt ihre kunst schätzchen
in genf zu lagern denn es gibt noch
etwas grundlegendes das ebenfalls viel
mit der schweizer finanz kultur zu tun
hat diskretion der genfer freihafen ist
ziemlich alt er ist kein besonders beim
röser ort aber das ist nicht wichtig
wenn man ein kunstwerk sehen weil es
braucht nur eine anständige beleuchtung
und die gewissheit dass alles gut
bewacht wird der ort ist praktisch und
zentral er ist ein sicherer arbeitsplatz
und die menschen schätzen situation
tournee sei jahres verkaufsdirektor der
fine art fand group sagen wir einfach
dass sie in der alten schweißerei liste
folgen wir stellen keine fragen du dir
vorstellen kannst ist das natürlich
keine politik die ohne kontroversen
auskommt
1994 wurde zum beispiel im genfer
freihafen antiquitäten entdeckt die aus
dem getty museum in los angeles
gestohlen worden waren im jahr 1993
wurden 200 aus ägypten gestohlen antike
stücke gefunden 2010 wurde dort eine
römische sarkophag entdeckt dessen
verschwinden in der türkei gemeldet
worden war und 2016 mussten zwei
etruskische sarkophage nach italien
zurückgebracht werden diese und andere
frühere skandale zu warnen die schweizer
zu reformen um die einfuhrbestimmungen
für diesen freihafen mit denen ähnlicher
zonen im rest der schweiz in einklang zu
bringen es müssen nun doch ein paar
klitzekleine fragen gestellt werden so
müssen importeure von kunstwerken gehen
wenn es ankommen nur den namen des
eigentümers die herkunft und den werther
gelagerten waren angeben und seit 2009
muss der genter freihafen auch ein
inventar aller dort zu finden
gegenstände für das problem viele stücke
ganz zu schweigen von den meisten wie
vor 2009 dort gelagert wurden konnten
nicht inventarisiert werden so dass nur
ihre besitzer wissen dass sie dort sind
und welchen wert sie wirklich haben
[Musik]
die lagerplätze im freihafen sind also
quasi so was wie anonyme schweizer
nummernkonten für kunstwerke und aus
diesem grund spielen sie eine wichtige
rolle auf dem globalen markt für
geldwäsche
vielen experten zufolge ist es relativ
einfach in gent mit einem fetten passen
illegal erworbener kohle anzukommen
damit ein gemälde zu kaufen und es
monate später weiter zu verkaufen um so
sauberes geld zu bekommen und das alles
spielt sich ganz bequem auf dem papier
beziehungsweise auf der festplatte ab
ohne auch nur eine einzige kiste mit
kunst anfassen zu müssen natürlich sind
nicht alle kunstliebhaber geldwäscher
aber wie wäre es wenn sie uns an dieser
stelle einmal ansehen wie eigentlich der
internationale kunstmarkt funktioniert
was er eigentlich darstellt warum
investieren so viele vermögende leute
ihr geld gerade in kunst wie viel geld
bewegt dieser markt jährlich welches
sind die führenden und aufstrebenden
länder im weltweiten kurs handel heute
werden wir all diese fragen beantworten
zuvor müssen wir aber noch selbst etwas
geld mit unserer kunst verdienen und
dieses bekommen wir von unserem sponsor
social web surft ist ein wirklich
sicheres vpn dass weder datenverkehr
noch meter oder verbindungsdaten mit lok
und außerdem jede menge security tools
mitbringt so schad ist aber auch aus
vielen anderen und ein ganz tolles
libyen natürlich könnt ihr mit dessen
hilfe auf websites und internet dienste
zugreifen in dem land in dem wir gerade
seid nicht verfügbar sind ohne zensur
und joe blob ob daheim oder im urlaub
darüber hinaus gibt es jedoch noch viele
weitere sicherheits-features habt ihr
nicht zb auch ein mulmiges gefühl durch
die allgegenwärtigen der pop ups und
coupés mit surft bekommt ein handliches
tool namens klien wird dass sie alle
bloggt und die damit verbundenen
gefahren beseitigt aber nicht nur das
mit nur einem server kommt oder könnt
ihr alle eure geräte im bpm registrieren
handys notebooks und sogar euren smart
tvs denkt wirklich alle arten von
geräten ab wie ihr bekommt damit einen
lückenlosen schutz so und weil wir euch
unsere treuen fans so lieb haben waren
wir nur bereit dieses sponsoring zu
übernehmen wenn euch selbst auch einen
ordentlichen rabatt eingeräumt und das
ist uns gelungen mit hilfe des
rabattcodes politik.de bekommt ihr sage
und schreibe 83
rabat und obendrein auf die ersten vier
monate gratis dazu denn links zu diesen
angebot findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter diesem video also nichts wie los
besorgt euch so auf start und hält damit
gleichzeitig auch uns damit für euch
weiterhin und so hunderte videos wie
dieses liefern können und jetzt wieder
zurück auf den geheimnisvollen
kunstmarkt
der kunstmarkt sichere wertanlage
[Musik]
woran denkst du wenn du dein geld in
eine sat anlage investieren möchte stan
immobilienaktien gold zufallszahlen nun
bei wirklich großen vermögen spielt auch
kunst eine wichtige rolle so
überraschend es auch sein mag die
wahrheit ist dass der kunsthandel es
geschafft hat die härtesten auswirkungen
der großen rezession zu überwinden und
sich als eine der sichersten geldanlagen
nichtfinanziellen charakters zu
positionieren die vor allem von großen
vermögen genutzt werden
wie du in dieser grafik sehen kannst ist
der geldfluss auf dem kunstmarkt in den
letzten zehn jahren ziemlich stabil
geblieben wir reden hier über einen
markt auf dem jedes jahr mehr als 60
milliarden dollar mit kunst umgesetzt
werden übrigens kannst du dir vorstellen
welche länder die hauptakteure auf
diesen markt sind nun dieses mal ist es
nicht die schweiz und in zwei länder die
sich die spitzenposition teilen die
vereinigten staaten und das vereinigte
königreich
zusammen machen sie mehr als 70 prozent
der weltweiten kunst ausfuhren aus
[Musik]
und ja ich weiß jetzt lassen sich viele
von euch fragen ok aber was hat das
alles eigentlich zu bedeuten warum wird
kunst von den reichen so hoch geschätzt
nun welt mit einen moment darüber nach
mit jedem jahr das vergeht verliert das
geld an wert unternehmen können allen
möglichen technologischen und
kommerziellen revolution ausgesetzt
seien und wenn du mir nicht glaubst
denkt einfach an einst hyper
erfolgreiche unternehmen wie kodak
blackberry oder blockbuster hörst du
heute noch was von denen wenn du kredite
vergibt oder anleihen kauft kann es sein
dass du mit zahlungsausfällen
konfrontiert wird und wenn du dann geld
in festverzinsliche anlagen investierst
du eine finanzkrise eintritt bestehen
auch viele risiken ein großteil seines
vermögens zu verlieren aber glaubst du
wirklich dass der wert eines mannes
eines van goghs oder eines picassos
eines tages sinken wird
glaubst du dass sie kniete kunz berühmte
künstler ihren wert verlieren könnte die
wahrheit ist dass es bisher nur wenige
fälle gegeben in denen ein berühmtes
kunstwerk zu einem niedrigeren preis
verkauft als es zuvor gekauft wurde und
genau das ermutigt die reichen dieser
welt ihre eigenen kunstsammlungen
anzulegen oder das erklärt auch warum
sie bereit sind manche stücke echte
vermögen auf den tisch zu legen im jahr
2017 wurde zum beispiel leonardo da
vinci c't salvator mundi in new york
versagte 450 millionen dollar verkauft
wird das richtig gehört 450 millionen
dollar
und beachtet dabei zwei wichtige dinge
die wir berücksichtigen müssen wenn du
über kunst sprechen der kunstmarkt ist
sehr verschlossen denn wenn du es nicht
vermasseln willst musst du dich wirklich
gut auskennen und natürlich können wie
auf dem anderen markt auch blasen
entstehen und die rentabilität ist alles
andere als sicher vor allem wenn du viel
für werke von fragwürdigem wert bezahlt
in jedem fall ist es so dass sich der
kunstmarkt insgesamt seit jahrzehnten
positiv entwickelt hat die haupttreiber
dabei sind die geldmengenausweitung
marktzinsen währungsabwertung und so
weiter sieh dir zum beispiel diese
grafik an die uns zeigt wie sich der
preis der teuersten zeitgenössischen
kunstwerke die seit 1989 verkauft wurden
entwickelt hat dem jahr 1989 wurde das
teuerste stück zeitgenössischer kunst
für etwas mehr als 20 millionen dollar
verkauft nun das teuerste stück das
letztes jahr 2019 verkauft wurde die
stars kultur alles kann dieses wurde für
satte 91 millionen dollar verkauft also
viermal so viel aber gehen sie noch
einen schritt weiter hast du dir
vorstellen in welchem land dieser markt
in den letzten jahren am stärksten
gewachsen ist nun ich denke dass du nie
im leben darauf kommen würdest
argentinien
ja das ist richtig gemessen am
exportvolumen von gemälden und
zeichnungen steht argentinien weltweit
an siebter stelle das land des tangos
hat mit dieser kommerziellen aktivitäten
im jahr 2009 10 483 millionen dollar
umgesetzt das sind hatte ich fest
1200 prozent mehr als im vorjahr kann
ich so übel aber das ist noch gar nichts
hatte ich lieber noch mal fest denn im
vergleich mit 2015 trug das wachstum gar
sagenhafte 56
1848 prozent
was zur hölle ist da nur in argentinien
los warum schießt der kurs macht
ausgerechnet dort in die höhe genau das
schauen wir uns jetzt
der überraschende fall argentiniens
wir haben es dir hier auch visuell
politik schon oft gesagt argentinien ist
wegen seiner bürokratie seiner
vorschriften seiner steuern und zölle
und einer ganzen reihe von
beschränkungen und hindernissen
wirtschaftlicher natur ein intrusion
vokabular ausgedrückt ökonomisches
schiphol ausgerechnet der kunstmarkt
scheint jedoch eine ausnahme zu bilden
in diesem bereich ist das argentinische
recht gemäßigt und sogar freier als das
vieler industrieländer
zum beispiel in argentinien nach der
änderung des gesetzes über den
internationalen warenverkehr von
kunstwerken im januar 2018 die verfahren
für deren aus- und einfuhren weiter
gelockert jetzt ist nur noch eine
ausfuhranmeldung für die werke von
künstlern erforderlich die mehr als 50
jahre verstorben sind dh die ausfuhr von
kunstwerken unterliegt weder eine lizenz
noch einer staatlichen kontrolle und das
in einem land in dem alles wirklich
alles in irgendeiner weise reglementiert
ist
und wenn wir dann noch verraten dass
dieses verfahren komplett online
durchgeführt werden kann wird es noch
interessanter
[Musik]
für werke von künstlern die ich vor mehr
als 50 jahren verstorben sind brauchst
du nur eine genehmigung des
kulturministeriums die du in weniger als
48 stunden erhalten kannst ja wäre in
argentinien doch nur alles so einfach
wie schön könnte das leben dort dann
sein tatsache ist dass du in argentinien
zum beispiel als tourist einreisen kunst
kaufen und sie ohne probleme als
handgepäck im flugzeug aus dem land
mitnehmen kannst außerdem erlaubt das
gesetz kunst aus dem ausland ins land zu
bringen und zwar ohne jegliche
einschränkungen bei messen oder
ausstellungen und ohne langwierige
bürokratische verfahren die zeit und
geld kosten würden tja wenn wir über
kunst sprechen sie da die linien in
vielerlei hinsicht einfach nicht aus die
argentinien
aber jetzt fragst du dich sicher warum
ist dort ausgerechnet dieser spezielle
markt so liberalisiert und der reguliert
worden kunst ist ja nicht gerade
lebensnotwendig warum befasst sich die
regierung eines landes in der dauerkrise
gerade mit etwas was für die große
mehrheit der notleidenden bevölkerung
wirklich nebensächlich ist nun das
offizielle argument lautet dass die
zirkulation argentinischer kunst in der
ganzen welt gefördert und damit der
nationale kunstmarkt gesteckt haben soll
als ob diese prämisse nicht
rechtfertigen würde genau dasselbe in
anderen wirtschaftszweigen zu tun die
für die menschen viel wichtiger sind
warum in aller welt ist kunst wichtiger
als diese nun wie ihr wisst sind wir
keine großen freund der abstruse
verschwörungstheorien aber genauso ist
eine prise gesunden misstrauen
angebracht dann etwas zu schön ist um
wahr zu sein politiker für nicht immer
nur gute dinge im schilde und gerade
diese geschichte hier fühlt sich nicht
ganz richtig an könnte es sein dass
argentinien so etwas mehr als zu einem
regionalen zentrum des kunstmarkts
geworden ist und sich eher etwas
düsteres verwandelt die vermutung liegt
auf dem tisch und die indizien
verdichten sich vor allem wenn man
bedenkt wie der rest der argentinischen
wirtschaft funktioniert aber das ist
schon wieder ein thema auf ein eigenes
video heute ging es ja um den freihafen
für kunstwerke deswegen bist du ist erst
mal an der reihe was ist deine meinung
über den kunstmarkt würdest du dein geld
dort investieren heißt du ihn für
wertstabile könntest du es mit einem
gewissen vereinbaren dass du damit
eventuell hilft schmutziges geld von
diktatoren schlächtern und drogen und
menschenhändlern zu waschen wie immer
sind wir auf eure meinung zu diesem
thema schon gespannt ich hoffe also dass
mich dieses video gefallen hat war es ja
gibt es einen live chat mit freunden und
vergisst nicht das abo mit glöckchen um
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
machs gut und bis bald
[Musik]